Je vais éclairer ceci
pour ma sœur et mon père qui
n'ont pas reçu l'aide dont ils avaient besoin
et qui sont décédés il y a un
an, donc c'est pour eux,
je m'appelle Connor, personne en
rétablissement soutenu, je m'appelle Lucas, je m'appelle
Kristen, je suis  Je suis alcoolique, je m'appelle Renata, je suis
une femme en convalescence, je m'appelle John, je suis
en convalescence depuis environ deux ans maintenant et
c'est la première fois que je fais
quelque chose comme ça. Je suis vraiment reconnaissante
d'être ici.  être avec des amis et être à
l'aise dans ma peau parce que ça fait
longtemps que je ne l'étais pas
merci
donc vous avez des enfants vous avez rejoint une
équipe c'est notre sixième
week-end d'aventure ce que je découvre c'est que nous nous
ressemblons plus que  nous sommes différents, les
situations ne sont peut-être pas exactement les mêmes,
mais il y a tellement de points communs
entre nous, donc quoi que vous vouliez faire, il y
a une tonne d'activités si vous le souhaitez, si
c'est votre week-end pour dormir
et vous ressourcer de cette façon, vous pouvez le
faire  ça aussi, mais je
vous encourage à vous impliquer si vous le pouvez.
Je ne suis probablement pas aussi avancé dans
ma sobriété que le reste d'entre vous et
je suis très gêné à ce sujet, euh,
à chaque fois que quelqu'un me le demande.  comme comment se passe
ma sobriété, je suis comme si c'était nul, je
déteste ça, c'est horrible et je suppose que
j'agissais de cette façon et cela se manifestait
par de l'agressivité parce que je suppose que je
voulais juste vraiment que les gens aiment voir ma douleur
mais je ne l'étais pas.  euh, je
l'exprime correctement donc je suis prêt à
ne pas être si résistant et j'espère que bientôt
quand les gens me demanderont comment ça va, je pourrai
vraiment dire que c'est bien, ça va
bien plus tôt, sobriété, ça craint
ouais tu sais, ça craint parce que
toi aussi  Je ressens des choses que tu n'as jamais ressenties, tu l'as
fait, j'ai court-circuité ces
choses, j'aime les traverser et tu
sais, parfois, je suis sobre, le fils de
tout est un vrai
catalyseur pour
la mort d'une de mes amies très proches,
elle était toxicomane.  aussi et n'a jamais vraiment
reçu l'aide dont elle avait besoin,
alors elle était en
quelque sorte sur le chemin de la guérison,
mais ça ne s'est pas très bien passé. J'ai eu
beaucoup de rechutes en cours de route. J'ai
ressenti beaucoup de colère et j'ai eu l'impression que je  Je suis
en quelque sorte obligé d'abandonner cette chose
qui était la seule chose qui
me faisait me sentir bien et maintenant je n'ai plus ça,
mais je sais qu'il existe
d'autres moyens d'éprouver ce sentiment
sans avoir besoin d'une béquille,
alors j'ai reçu un coup de pied.  J'ai quitté la Marine, ce qui
m'a envoyé dans une spirale incontrôlable.
Je savais que je ne préparais rien de bon dès
mon retour à la maison, alors je me suis assuré de
pousser mes proches aussi loin que
possible.
J'ai été expulsé d'où je me trouvais.  je vivais
donc je n'avais personne qui
me surveillait, mes amis étaient tous ennuyés contre moi, je
gardais tout le monde très éloigné donc
c'était très isolant mais je l'ai choisi et
ensuite je ne pouvais pas
aimer
revenir, je suppose que
je vraiment  Je voulais garder mon
enfer personnel, honnêtement, très secret, la
dépendance est l'une de ses caractéristiques, c'est l'
isolement, ce sera comme ça,
oh mon Dieu, il y
a des oranges, elles sont sauvages,
mes parents ont été négligents, ils ne l'ont pas fait,
ils étaient juste là.  faire leur propre
truc, tu sais, la drogue et tout ça et quand
j'avais 18 ans et j'ai bu une demi-bouteille de
vodka et c'était le début, c'était
le début mais j'aurais aussi dû mourir
cette nuit-là, j'ai bu
tous les jours à partir de la minute où
je me suis réveillé  Je me suis levé le matin jusqu'à
m'évanouir, c'était vraiment très grave, je suis allé
à l'église, je suis allé à leurs
réceptions scolaires, ce n'est pas comme si notre comportement était
toujours excusable, n'est-ce pas, mais comme si nous étions
malades, je sais, je sais à quoi ressemblait ta
réalisation.  moment où tu voulais
arrêter de boire
je travaillais chez Amazon et je voulais
mourir je buvais beaucoup tous
les soirs quand je rentrais à la maison je me défonçais
au travail je pensais sauter
du balcon parce que je travaillerais le
troisième ou  quatrième étage et j'ai eu une
crise de panique, j'ai eu une grave crise de panique et je me suis
retrouvé à l'hôpital, ce sont les choses les plus
extrêmes, mais c'est comme si c'était un
signal d'alarme, ouais, c'est comme si je
ne pouvais pas continuer à vivre dans cette douleur, mais je ne
le fais pas non plus.  Je ne sais pas s'il y a d'autres
options, j'avais l'impression de ne pas vivre et puis
quand j'avais 28 ans, je me suis rétabli et
puis ma vie a commencé, donc je
dis toujours que ma vie a commencé à 28 ans et maintenant je
suis sobre depuis deux ans et demi.  ouais,
moins génial La vie est belle,
je me souvenais de l'hypothèse selon laquelle
une personne souffrant de troubles liés à la consommation d'alcool était
une sorte de personne échevelée buvant de
l'alcool dans un sac
[Musique]
alors qu'en réalité, ces personnes pourraient
me ressembler et je pense que j'ai l'air plutôt bien
organisée aujourd'hui par  que je me présente et que je sois
simplement qui je suis. J'espère que cela
éliminera la stigmatisation parce que nous pouvons
ressembler à n'importe qui, que ce soit un garçon ou une fille.
[Musique]
Je sentais que je protégeais d'une certaine manière les
gens que j'aime de toute la
négativité qui  J'avais l'impression d'avoir
réalisé récemment que les gens s'en soucient et
qu'ils veulent aider et repousser cela
comme si c'était égoïste de faire ça.
[Musique] mes
proches dans ma vie tirent aussi beaucoup d'avantages
de leur offre d'aide et vous êtes un
actif  dépendance, je ne sais pas, tu te
sens si isolé ou tu t'es isolé,
d'accord, la clé
en fait, c'est comme la communauté
[Musique]
ici pour savoir que tu n'es pas seul et qu'il y a des
gens de tous les groupes d'âge
mais beaucoup  du moment où ils
traversent les mêmes cercles que toi,
tu dois tirer très
fort
[Musique]
étrangère,
ça t'aide à être rassuré sur le fait que
tu es sur la bonne voie.
J'ai réalisé que j'en avais vraiment besoin.
j'aime les gens, il n'est pas nécessaire de se
concentrer sur la récupération de la sobriété,
c'est comme être une personne comme
parler à nouveau à tout le monde pour les savoir
traîner et rire, mais il y
a toujours cette couche de genre, nous pouvons devenir
comme un très vrai
bien, je'  J'ai quatre ans et demi d'abstinence, donc
je pense que c'est ma quatrième année, génial
ouais,
bien, c'est un bon
blaireau, c'est un bon chien et euh, si
quelque chose m'arrive, je laisse Jake avec
toutes mes dettes, merci,
je n'y vais pas presque.  high,
je n'ai jamais fait ça auparavant, tellement de plaisir
ici, c'est comme ça, d'accord,
tu te prépares, non parce que tu as l'air prêt, d'accord,
prenons trois fois de plus
[Musique]
Je gère la plupart de mes mauvais jours maintenant en
tendant la main à quelqu'un.  en parlant à
quelqu'un
[Musique]
nous allons passer à la méditation
pour vérifier les vêtements
pour permettre à ta respiration d'être naturelle
[Musique]
faire les choses seul n'est pas ce n'est pas
sain nous étions censés être près du
feu il y a une raison pour laquelle notre  les ancêtres
sont descendus des grottes
sont venus autour du feu parce que nous avons besoin
les uns des autres en ce
moment
je suis assis ici
est un oiseau
comme tu sais un bon feu, bonne compagnie
et comme si
tout allait bien en ce moment je suis avec
des gens je tiens à moi je me soucie  à propos d'eux,
je sais que nous allons manger des s'mores plus tard,
qui l'a mieux que nous, tu sais et
euh et j'aurais pu tout rater J'aurais pu
tout rater
quand j'aime avoir commencé le traitement J'étais tellement comme si
je connaissais toujours tout le monde  dit que
j'étais tellement brisé comme si je n'étais pas une
personne et que je ne voulais pas l'être et une
chose dont je me souviens vraiment c'est que le premier
mois de PHP, le patient hospitalisé, il y avait un
autre colocataire et moi et lui
parlions une nuit et lui à  à un moment donné,
je pense que c'était deux ou trois
ans de sobriété, puis j'ai rechuté et
c'est pourquoi il était là et je me souviens d'
être resté éveillé tard avec lui en train de parler et j'étais
comme lui choisir le cerveau, je me disais,
comment c'était comme si je pouvais'  J'essayais
de comprendre ce que ça ferait d'
avoir deux trois. Je me demandais comment c'était.
Je n'avais pas eu plus de quelques jours et je
ne sais même pas depuis combien d'années à ce moment-là
il était comme ça.  j'avais l'impression d'être libre
je comprends ce qu'il dit maintenant
c'est normal de ressentir de la douleur et de souffrir c'est
une chose humaine
c'est bien d'aimer être vulnérable être ouvert être à l'
aise être mal à l'aise c'est
mieux de l'autre côté c'est
clair c'est plus heureux c'est
génial
[Musique]
merci  tu